now women at 35 years old still won't
adapt to the market she can't find the
511 dude that wants her that she finds
attractive so it might be time to be
desperate why is desperation always a
bad thing you know what I mean how
she also said she's been on the dating
apps for five years now the issue you're
going to have on dating apps is that
women only swipe right on dating apps
five percent of the time so if you're
going on a date on a dating app as a
woman you're probably at a disadvantage
not because you're at a disadvantage
throughout all of dating apps but the
guy you're on a date with probably
has a ton of options and isn't going to
treat you very special all right I'm
just I'm just being honest because the
guys that we tend to swipe on have all
the women are swiping on